okay so a bunch of people talk i got
that too
listen so people are saying that this is
chapelle
oh this was sent in from asano and matt
adams on instagram
i i i'll just watch it
[Music]
i log on to instagram and all of a
sudden i have like
a bunch of notifications yeah like like
a bunch
and i'm like what the hell is going on
and then i noticed it was the same
thing that people were tagging me and so
then i watched the video i was like
they gotta [ __ ] they gotta be running
yeah
they got you guys
do we know what happened to him he feels
probably i guarantee he's fine
he's fine that big boy
hey what was he thinking he floated you
know what honestly playing against
like i thought he was gonna win i never
thought he was gonna land it was
that was just
[Applause]
he thought he was nice with it
why is this big ass on that little
scooter anyways i feel like he used to
do this when he was younger and
weighed less and he was like i still got
it listen i know my [ __ ] lane i know
how much i weigh
oh my god i know what i can do straight
up backflips all day
anything else no yeah hold on dude go
back to that if he
just pulled his feet down a little bit
more hold on
because his feet were behind him so
that's what slowed him down
yeah you know he's probably landed there
before you can tell by the confidence
look at the ride
one of those ramps yeah that's scary
yeah you know what i'm saying
look at this oh he was all [ __ ]
but look at the confidence to ride up no
look at the rider
look at the ride up like y'all don't do
they have this home they don't even know
huh do they have this homie's instagram
i bet it's via dxo
oh no no no no no do you think it's that
yeah or the other one it probably
because we gotta give this race
no that's not him that's not see what's
the other one x x underscore
send you two t-shirts duty
i was i knew he was legit there's no way
yeah oh he
go that boy is yeah yes
wait hold on you fell again oh you show
you the falls and then he show you
oh look at that damn he's nice with it
he's so nice with it
ah
damn nice bro i have to follow this dude
let me see what else he has what's his
instagram it's uh
they call him underscore dot patchy
with he's in uk where he's killing oh
he's in the uk please read that
shout out to the uk x dot underscore dot
patchy
i love you got the smiley face in his
name he didn't post him busting his ass
no i know right he didn't post that
people people love to post i hope he's
okay
dude would it kill you to lose some
weight though bro let him no let him
have it don't have it you don't have it
would be better it's a lot more uh come
on he's probably better than most people
yeah on a scooter most people can't do
what he's doing
look how he's look how he whipping that
scooter he whipping that's dope
he's killing it wait see if they should
see if he posts this fall
nah cause you know why they scream your
failures but whisper
no i bet you i bet you yeah he's had to
post that this one is
june 2019 so it would have to be all the
way no scroll no scroll down
but he didn't probably just it's one of
those things that probably could
possibly resurface
yeah because i think yeah that's
probably okay now he didn't post it
no that looks like the same skate park
he'd been
like he like man i've been falling all
this time now y'all gonna post this this
guy's a king
mm-hmm this guy's a [ __ ] king i like
him bro
bro i respect him all the way bruh don't
lose your weight maybe yeah if you big
and you still killing me
i can still skateboard and that's
impressive
right come on now he's 18 though
he has a lot of living to do he does
yeah
but he's saying that he's at that
fearless mode 18 you're fearless
but that's what i'm saying i wonder how
far you can take it if you were to get
real serious
wait they have this one he probably
loses weight from just doing that
they have scooter in the ass he's
probably gonna yeah i don't think so i
don't know i don't think
not that mini scooter no they don't have
that i like this guy though yeah i
respect him all the way
a mushroom yeah i got tagged so many
still getting tagged [ __ ] funny
people just saying nothing's funny one
guy when people attack somebody when
that guy's in the line at walmart
wait wait i didn't see that wait
yeah some black dude singing there's a
little blonde guy behind him everyone
that was theo
yeah oh yeah someone thought that yeah
super
far here's another clip that we didn't
bring up uh last week
right cat dude yeah there's another one
people tagged
me and you dude i got tagged in this one
too what is this people won't leave me
alone
i get it i'm thick but i'm not [ __ ]
that yeah but there's
very oh so what he got you want to do
it he got you he goes oh what he found
he blew his back
back out i look like that's what's going
on scorpio
this guy's comment goes okay we see you
as if we had a choice
[Laughter]
youtube comments i mean uh instagram for
comments are the first [ __ ] it was funny
damn it broke his spinal cord shouts out
to big homie though
mm-hmm i respect you in these bad dudes
i know dude i get technology you're not
fat yeah yeah i'm bbm yeah i'm bbi
don't get a twist yeah do not get that
[ __ ] twisted when i get off stage with
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son